[Music]
let's go out to Toledo Ohio and talk to
Mara Mary what's up
Mary hi what's
up uh nothing nuts I am really really
nervous I love your show though I do not
miss an episode so you're too excited
thank you so so much what's up um so my
question is
how do I communicate with my husband
without um him becoming quite defensive
we've only been married for about two
and a half years so still kind of new to
all of this but it's been pretty
prevalent since I'd say since we were
engaged um I feel like whenever I ask
him a question or just kind of having
difficult conversations it just kind of
goes over like a bag of bricks and I'm
not really sure what I'm doing doing
wrong or how I'm contributing to it I've
tried to ask them in the moment and
outside of those heated moments how I
could phrase my questions to make them
less offensive but he has kind of told
me that he doesn't want to tell me how
because it that just feels weird to tell
him to tell me how to communicate with
him um the questions can range from
finances hold hold hold on hold on hold
on you are being gaslit out of your mind
my
friend
oh let me be like super clear you can't
he is choosing to be
offended
period he's either choosing to be
offended by what you
say he's choosing to be offended by
going back in and back in and back into
the same
conversations and he's choosing to or
he's choosing to be offended by not
giving you Clues as to why what you say
hurts him
I kind of have I do have in like I do
know
why um he's got a lot of Shame from his
past he's got a lot of stuff that
happened when he was a kid that care
don't care here's why me
too and my wife doesn't have to carry
that I
do like your job is not to tiptoe and
dance around him for the rest of your
marriage his job is he said I do he says
I love you till the end of
time I find it un I find myself unable
to have these hard conversations to you
based on childhood sexual abuse based on
being poor based on any number of things
that might have happened to him and it's
his responsibility to go get the help
and healing and care that he needs so he
can dial in to his
wife that's his job and he is doing that
he's been going to therapy for a few
months now I think okay probably almost
half a year and it has helped like good
I I have seen improvements he's not
living in fight or flight mode which
I've told him you know I've encouraged
him from the beginning when we were
engaged I was like you need to go deal
with that stuff because you deserve kind
of like you I've heard you say like you
deserve to be well it's not because
you're
defective you just deserve that so I've
encouraged him he he is doing that he's
doing the work and we're actually going
to go in together to talk to his
therapist about this because
perfect um yeah that's this week um so I
wrote this before we decided that but I
was like I just don't feel like we can
have this conversation we just can't
find a resolution and I I need a third
party or something because I just I
don't understand and it's just been hard
because every
time his default kind of is just to say
that I don't trust
him and unfortunately yes he has made a
couple of you know mistakes where the
trust was broken and it was it was awful
because he accused me of that before it
happened so when I found out and it's
just and that was just finan like a
financial thing it was misusing a credit
card that we both knew we were like we
were going to get one and I wanted to
talk about how to use it but he thought
that me asking like having that
conversation of what our expectations
were he thought that that was me not
trusting him and basically accusing him
of overspending and then that's kind of
what happened hold on hold
on hold on
Mary why didn't you look him in the eye
and say honey I don't trust
you because like after the fact when he
says oh you don't trust
me why don't you say I can't trust you
because I don't
know
it's like I feel like I you know we had
those conversations after all that
happened and I've really want to you
know I've forgiven him hold on and it's
not just like sitting in the back of my
head I just don't no it's sitting in
your nervous
system it's a part of you
now and he won't take ownership of it
and Mary every time I try to point
something out that he needs to go do you
defend him and you protect
him what is it about what what is it
about why when did you have you had the
job of Peacekeeper your whole
life
no I don't think so my I I grew up with
really great parents and the
conversation was anything was on the
table like to this day like they're
still
like
they
they're just really easy to talk to and
I
don't that's why I've just been so
confused CU I've you know I've done the
introspection like what is it like is it
me it's am I something it's not
you and it's almost like you you would
rather it be you because you don't want
to deal with the alternative that it's
him it's Absol absolutely absurd that a
husband will not talk to his wife about
finances period
period it's absurd I would tell any
grown man on planet Earth
that you know why because I have held
wives whose husbands have died who look
me terrified in the eyes and say I don't
know where anything is and I don't know
what to do
next they don't know where the insurance
papers are they don't know where the
mortgage they don't know who they don't
even know what a mortgage is they don't
even know what it
is it's
absurd anytime somebody in a marriage
says the words oh you don't trust me I
call bull crap on
that because I I feel like he doesn't
trust me like I guess with information
like knowing stuff does he know that
though have you been that honest with
him I I told him yes I said look this is
just an observation but I feel like
you don't want me and I I've seen this
with other people but me too he doesn't
want me to know kind of like what he's
got going on in his head his plans when
he's going to do things why he's doing
things what it is because he doesn't
want he he he's afraid that maybe I'll
try to like control him or blackmail or
judge him and I know that yeah it's
probably coming from the shame based
place but it's not okay it's it just you
know what it is infidelity it's
infidelity people get obsessive about
infidelity being about who had sex with
who I think Fidelity in marriage is way
bigger than that yeah it is somebody
going
elsewhere is what that is living an
alternative life a double
life a life separate from their person
that they said I
do
and I think there's you are
so I think you're such an introspective
person and you're such a kind person you
are doing everything you can to look in
the mirror and figure out what you have
done to deserve this and I'm telling you
third party nothing that you've told
me and where I think that is scarier for
you that means you have to drop your
shoulders and exhale and probably weep
pretty hard because your marriage isn't
what you thought it
was or your husband's not who you
thought he
was and that's terrifying
right
yeah like I said we you know he is very
wanting to very much wanting to work on
this so I don't feel like you know it's
a dead end and we're not going to sure
you know get through it I just it's just
lot yeah it is a lot especially for
someone like you who has seen the other
side you've seen how amazing it is when
people are just open and put everything
on the table and talk through things and
disagree and fight and laugh and carry
on that's the home you grew up in right
yeah yeah you know what the other side
feels like and you're watching somebody
self- select into
Suffocation and think they're winning
and you're like no I know what it's like
when everybody's just laughing and
breathing
yeah and so it's extra
hard some people when two people marry
each other and they both come from
abusive households sometimes there's
this fantasy about what things could be
like it's not a fantasy to you you've
lived
it yeah right and it's terrifying that
he won't participate in that to answer
your question whole you're doing the
exact right thing which is y'all are
going to a counselor together okay
here's what's going to be underneath
that
I want you to spend some time between
now and going to see that counselor and
if it's in a couple of days amazing and
I want you to spend some direct
time and this is going to be scary
writing down what you want and what you
need and when you talk to him I don't
want you to use words with the counselor
because the counselor going to say what
would you like to say and I don't want
you to say things like well I feel that
you cuz the moment you do that he has to
go on the
defense I want you to have the courage
and the strength to look at your husband
in a safe therapist office and
say I have to know what's going on
financially in our
home I have to know what is in your mind
when it comes to planning thinking about
our future cuz this isn't just your
future this is our
future I want you to say honey I am so
scared I can't
breathe because I feel like I'm alone in
my own
house I sleep next to a man I love and I
feel completely
alone and when you do that what you're
doing is you are talking not about him
but about
you and he has to feel and learn the the
impact his
choices have on his
wife not under ATT
attack you say I feel dumb when you tell
me don't worry about
it I feel unsafe when I wake up every
day and I don't know where the insurance
papers are and I don't know how much
money we have in the account I don't
know how much money you've
borrowed mhm see what I'm saying this
makes it all about
you and what you've been doing for the
last however many years is trying to
make it all about him and how you can
fix him you can't that's the scary part
you it sounds like he's making the
choices to do something different that's
[Music]
cool but just going to counseling isn't
going to help I mean it's it is going to
help but it's not enough he's gonna have
to start acting
differently
yeah and so how can you going back to
your original question how can you say
things in a way that won't be offensive
to
him he has to have the courage to tell
you here's what I need from you when we
talk and he can't say oh that's just too
weird okay then you are choosing
offense you know what I mean you're
choosing that yeah yeah it's like people
who watch Chappelle stand
up either hey they watch it they they
they click on
it and they just sit there and get
offended the whole
time it's like you turned it on or two
yeah you don't email Dave Chappelle I
don't if he's got an email and say hey
when you say these three things it's
very very
hurtful yeah right then you're at least
saying it and then I'm out I'm not going
to keep clicking on
that
[Music]
mm but I don't know what's going on in
your sweet husband's head but I need you
to know it's not your
fault it's not your
fault and I know that's scary but it's
not your
fault write down what you want write
down what you need and when you sit down
with the counselor and him make it about
what is happening to you
and it's going to feel like you're
attacking him you are not you are
telling him the
truth I'm
scared I feel
dumb I feel
unloved let's start there I'm proud of
you proud of you trying to figure out
every way you can possibly love this
man it's time for him to continue his
healing journey and he's got to start
changing the way he does things
hopefully you and him and this new
counselor can find a path forward be
thinking about you
guys